the Audion oka River has flooded but
while some locals fish from the river
others in the city of Puerto yaku Cho in
Venezuela's amazonas state are having
trouble getting enough food doctor Elvis
aragua works at the main hospital in
Amazonas areas where patients are
supposed to be treated are contaminated
and there are few supplies these
facilities are supposed to accommodate
indigenous populations from remote
communities but now they're empty more
than 50 children died of malnutrition
here in the last few months in the midst
of a national nursing strike the
hospital is no longer safe for
indigenous people there were even more
fatalities that were not reported maybe
at a fear of the World Health
Organization but it's good that this
situation has now been publicized
worldwide the chief of the PA poco
ethnic minority has called a town
meeting dr. r agua has met with an
indigenous organization to treat the
local children and deliver medicine the
number of children dying of malnutrition
has increased in rural areas where
malaria and measles outbreaks have
recurred one boy from the piatto ethnic
group was hospitalized until a few days
ago until his grandparents took him home
Octavio Castro is the chief of Chania
Gloria where malaria is widespread more
than half the community works in illegal
mining operations
they've neglected traditional
agriculture we're trying to plant
something for the sake of the children
there are problems because shamans
cannot heal these diseases Mira Maria
Eugenia grille yet a Venezuelan
researcher blames the resurgence of
malaria on the boom and illegal mining
throughout southern
Orinoco the deforestation and ditches
filled with stagnant water lead to the
spread of mosquitoes that carry the
disease
Juliet is calling for joint efforts with
international organizations to fight the
epidemic the Health Ministry should
collaborate with the pan-american Health
Organization and various health-related
NGOs in Venezuela along with academies
and international groups like Doctors
Without Borders because they know
exactly how to tackle a problem at its
current level we have an epidemic that's
out of control hunger epidemics and the
economic crisis are bearing down on the
children of Amazonas State the future of
Venezuela's indigenous populations is
under threat